Oh,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight and entering the code named Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy from men.
Holla at your boy.
Don't be scared.
You could shoot loads.
Eddie discount.
And Chris will tell you he used to be Chris.
That's a long story.
No,
his name is Aubrey.
It's going to get dirty.
Ladies and gentlemen,
my Buddy Chris,
formerly known as Chris,
the artist,
formerly known as Chris.
Isn't the house Chris though.
What's up?
Buckle up pitches.
The Joe Rogan experience.
They get stopped.
[inaudible]
this podcast is,
uh,
been very interesting for a number of reasons.
A,
it's been a weird little ride.
Unexpected we never thought were going to do this to so totally came out of
nowhere.
Just me and Brian just fucking around.
But one of the
best parts about it has been the,
uh,
the ability to get all these people together to get,
all these,
uh,
cool dudes that were friends with and really spend a lot of time with them,
much more time than we would have spent with them talking about shit,
if we didn't have a podcast,
you know,
like Brian Kaylin and I mean,
we've really gotten deep into who Dunkin is.
Man.
I know Dunkin so much more over this last year.
Yeah.
So it went from like going to a comedy club and saying hi to somebody like,
oh,
how was your week to actually digging into this person for two to three hours?
Yeah.
Finding out
their thoughts on everything.
Politics,
religion,
life and death.
And,
um,
Chris is one of the,
uh,
more interesting cats that we've met along the way,
and he's responsible for getting us together with the flashlight.
Uh,
that was,
uh,
the first group,
the first person ever that offered to sponsor us,
you know,
and,
uh,
and he's also,
um,
you know,
he's an interesting dude and he's,
uh,
I'm glad that we met.
You're,
you're,
um,
you're a unique character and a real one.
You're a real one.
There's a lot of people out there pretending to be guys like you,
but they're not really,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
uh,
you're,
you're just,
um,
I'm just very happy we met.
I'm very happy we're friends like this,
uh,
this latest experience that you have gone on as one of the reasons why I really,
I really did you,
um,
he's the real gently,
he's the real deal.
He got off and he flew to fucking Peru and uh,
he went to the jungle with those root eaten motherfuckers.
And how did you sleep in camps?
What did you yeah,
it was a little hot open.
How many days were you down there for?
I was in a,
in the jungle for six and then out in the mountains for another six or seven.
No,
he got so fucked up on the style of Wasco.
Then he changed his name died Joe.
I had to come back.
Something else.
He,
he changed.
He used to be Chris,
and now he's Aubrey
or you're murdered somebody and you're running,
running from the Peruvian authority.
Fascinated.
I'm perplexed.
I'm horrified.
I'm all of the above.
Uh,
so let's get into it.
So how did you find out about this,
this place?
How do you,
uh,
for those who don't know what Iowasca is,
Iowasca is the orally active version of the most potent psychedelic drug known
to man,
which is dimethyltryptamine and dimethyltryptamine is produced by the human
body.
They don't understand why,
but they,
they,
they believe that it's produced during heavy rem sleep and during periods of
extreme stress,
they don't know what it is.
They don't know what it's real,
true function is.
But they do know that it is the most incredible hallucination,
hallucination,
creating visionary,
psychedelic experience known to man.
It's mind boggling,
incredible experience.
But it's not orally active cause it's in so many different plants that if you,
uh,
if you got it orally from eating it,
man,
you people would go on DMT trips all the time because it's an all sorts of
different grasses and plants and usually in a combin atory,
um,
state with a bunch of other,
you know,
whether they're active or non psychoactive ingredients.
Like some plants actually contain five methoxy Diane dimethyl trip doing,
which is another form of DMT that's a justice I should actually more powerful
but unique and different than the regular DMT experience.
But we're getting off track.
This W IOWASCA is,
is the Shamans of South America figured out and no one knows how long ago they
figured this out,
whether it's a thousand years,
10,000 years,
it's all guesswork because there's no written history of it.
They figured out how to combine the reason why it's not orally active as your
stomach produces something called mono aiming oxidase.
And that breaks down dimethyl trip to mean in the oral form.
So once it gets to your stomach where any,
you know,
we're were like marijuana when you eat it,
it would get into your bloodstream.
What can cause the motto?
Aiming oxidase crushes it.
So what they figured out how to do is take the route of one plant,
the leaves of one plant and the vine of another plant.
And they don't even grow near each other.
They're on other completely other parts.
Yeah,
the Dongle.
And there's over a hundred thousand different types of plants in the jungle.
So the fact that they figured out how to do this and thousands of years ago,
and when you ask them,
who knows if they're telling you the truth,
but what they say is that the plants taught them how to do that.
They look at you like you're a big dummy.
When you asking me like how did you,
how did you find that out?
And they're like,
they told us.
I mean,
you know,
it's like that matter of fact when you're talking to the real deal down there,
it's not like they come up with an elaborate story.
They just look at you like,
well obviously they told us how he,
you think drink,
we just guessed,
you know,
like come on,
they told you.
Well,
you know what I mean?
That seems to be a,
an actual possibility.
That to me is more likely than they figured it out through trial and error.
The combination there,
if you're,
you know,
I don't know,
I'm not a math unless cyber guy,
but it also could be evidence of an ancient civilization that figured out,
you know,
plant pharmacology thousands and thousands of years before.
I'm sure there's a lot of medicines that are you putting two different things
that had nothing to do with each other together.
There's,
there's one particular one called Cura,
which is,
which they use and if they don't do it exactly the right way,
it's a deadly,
deadly,
toxic poison.
But the way that they're able to do it,
um,
you know,
it's just pretty miraculous that punching people haven't died.
So there's plenty of examples.
Yeah,
it's a,
what is curare?
Is it an medicine?
I think it's a,
I think that's the medicine,
right?
I think there's a,
it's the way that they prepare it and uh,
I don't know some shit that they would put on poison darts and shooting.
Oh Man.
Maybe I have that.
I don't know because I'm thinking I'm only going from like Tarzan.
Yeah,
maybe that is the poison dart thing,
but you know how to spell it.
How do you spell it?
You are a
e c u r a r e
thing with the preparation.
I think of it where if they,
if they did it wrong,
Bam.
Nasad for common name for various Arrow poisons.
Okay.
So that's originating in South America.
Well,
I guess if you do it right,
it kills people maybe with the boys or something like that.
But the point is,
it's amazing that these people figured out long before we,
you know,
wherever driving cars or sending emails,
they figured out how to combine these two plants and make an orally active
version of dimethyltryptamine that in the words of the showman connects you to
the spirit world.
And the idea is that there is a world that is all around us all the time,
but we just cannot tune into it.
And it is a world of souls and it is a world of the afterlife and is a world of
non in bodied entities that are to the experience or to the,
to the subjective person that's having these experience there as real,
if not more real than this life itself.
I was their brother,
I saw it.
I mean I was in it and it was completely indisputable for me.
And that was what was so life changing.
What was indisputable?
Tell us what happened.
You go down there and so you got to write a whole thing to get in there.
What happened?
So it's kind of a school
I've been studying and training and,
and uh,
going to classes and things led by a master showman who's found out the best in
South America,
learned from him for 30 years and is now trying to teach people here in the u s
about it.
So,
uh,
in order to get into this,
this is kind of like the masterclass here.
This is the finishing course going down and taking the medicine down in the,
in the Amazon.
So in to get admitted I had to write,
you know,
write a letter and they reviewed it and you know,
did whatever they do to kind of approve me to go along.
But eventually I was like,
did you have to go through any stages besides writing the letter?
This is the masterclass.
This was,
it was kind of,
yeah,
this is like the uh,
this is like the ultimate field trip at the end of the,
at the end of the school,
you know,
where you actually really get to test out on you,
what you wrote.
Um,
I could get it in my email.
I would love to read it all.
It's cheesy glory cause I know it has to be,
probably put some emotional shit in there.
Like,
Oh of course my cats.
No,
that's not the kind of Shit you put in there man.
He talked spiritual warrior journey type of poetry shit.
You talk about your intent.
What did,
what did,
so what did you say in basically a letter basically just said,
you know,
about my intent to explore these realms of consciousness.
You know,
why I wanted to do it,
you know,
I wanted to go there,
learn,
grow and bring something back.
And um,
and that was,
you know,
really the gist of it.
And I sent it back to you with a gold star.
Yeah,
they gave me the thumbs up.
There's a willy Wonka golden ticket to meet the spirit world.
That's it.
Okay.
So you get there,
you fly in,
so fly in,
you take a van out to the camp.
Like how do you get to the,
well,
we fly and then we take another flight out to place called Puerto Maldonado and
one of these planes.
Decent size plant.
I've got a lot.
No,
no,
no.
I had a real job.
It was a jet.
Okay.
Yeah.
But then we take a,
then we take a canoe,
a two hour canoe.
I mean,
we arrived at credit mall and it's like a,
I'll tell you to go fuck yourself.
It's like a real third world country.
I mean it's just,
you smell feces and fish and smiling happy people,
but it's like dust and diesel fuel and it's one of those places to our canoe
just into the middle of nowhere.
Like on the Amazon,
Amazon,
the Madre de Dios river.
Since I've been watching a lot of that Jeremy Wade's river monsters.
So I'm just looking at this muddy brown water thinking of these way.
He that burrow through people flash and soft fish and all those things he's
pulled out of there.
Um,
but yeah,
three hours up is,
you know,
two and a half or so up the,
up the river to this place.
It was just this eco lodge running on generators out in the middle of the jungle
and generators that are fueled by,
is it bio diesel?
Like how do they straight diesel out?
Just get it from a source.
Do you have a truck come by and deliver it?
They have one big ship comes up the river and degenerate is on for a certain
amount of time,
about three hours,
three hours at a time.
So the hours,
refrigerators?
Um,
no,
not good ones I guess.
But the food was great,
so I didn't,
I didn't really probe too deeply.
Maybe they keep the kitchen part on generation more,
but the lights and everything like that that we got about two and a half hours a
day.
Wow.
Yeah.
So at nighttime it was just dark as fuck and right when you'd start the
ceremony,
that's when the lights would kick and it just boom.
And then with the canopies above,
I mean it's just cave black.
Now do they have to worry about Jaguars that they do,
but the Jaguars is a very sacred animal to them,
you know,
so it's cool.
Right,
right.
Well they believe that that's what happens to us when we,
uh,
once he die anyways,
you ain't sacred
to them,
man,
I'll tell you that.
No,
they have a totally different fucking game plan they're playing with totally
different rule book.
Yeah.
But there was Jaguar tracks while we were there and some of the places we were
hiking,
God damn son,
Jaguars are like mountain lions on steroids.
There's quote Ninja Ninja,
mountain lions.
They're killers,
man.
There's curious.
Fuck yeah.
Okay.
So you,
you get to this camp,
you were two hours on a canoe and do you speak this language?
What language do they speak?
Spanish,
they speak spent.
Do you speak Spanish and Poquito.
Poquito so,
uh,
did you bring like Rosetta stone with you or did you just kind of,
I dunno.
I mean just tried to get by.
It actually got a little bit tough for when I was trying to speak about things
that are not commonplace.
Like with the my stroke,
the head Sharman let me try and communicate with external to call him maestro
maestro or don't,
don't Orlando my store Orlando was a,
was the guy I work with.
So Maestro is an interesting name cause you know,
you think of someone for a ride back to them,
their master of the plants,
what they call it.
So is that Spanish?
The plots show is a master master of the,
but these stuffs vegetal these tests,
right?
Yeah.
And isn't that one of the names for the,
there's,
there's two,
two different churches I believe in North America that have one through the
supreme court.
The ability to take Iowasca in a ceremonial Christian religion,
one that named Santo diamond.
The other one is the vegetal these stuff.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And they were in like New Mexico or something like that.
So,
um,
you're down there in the jungle.
Okay.
You,
you get to the camp.
Do you say,
hi,
let's,
let's fucking do this.
We show up and there was like a general orientation.
They feed us.
Great federally speaking.
You and English.
Both English and Spanish.
That organized?
It's organized.
Yeah.
There was like 50 of us going down there.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a big troop man.
See that would trip me out like getting blasted with a bunch of Weirdos that I
didn't know it was,
it was interesting.
They were all super good natured,
but this is not the crew that I would bring on board.
Like I see where the vessel,
if I was going to,
you know,
lots of broken people.
Right.
I think they started that way and this was an answer for a lot of people,
but you know,
genuinely good people.
I was,
I was impressed to see that they weren't a lot of these super kind of fraudulent
pseudo spiritual,
like,
I'm so connected,
you know,
they were like really good people.
Like they were,
they were out to help you.
But they,
there's,
they,
there's like the saltiest crew.
I would say that element of insincerity is,
uh,
is really one of the biggest problems with human beings.
And in a sense,
a lot of people,
whatever you become,
anything,
you got to fake it before you make it.
You know,
like,
I've had this conversation with my friends about comics that are,
comics are just starting out and like the,
you know,
let's not fucking colligate is fucking terrible.
I'm like,
God damn,
man,
if you saw me a weekend to my act,
you would want to kill me too.
You know,
I was a faker.
I was a faker until it became a comic.
But there's something about the spiritual thing.
It's like faking spirituality is one of the grossest thing.
It's even grosser faking being a
rock star.
You know,
like if you're in fucking high school and you're wearing black nail Polish and
you're growing your hair long,
you decide to like fake,
like you're a rockstar until you become a rock star.
You know what I mean?
Well cause faking to be a rockstar actually helps you to be a rock.
Start faking to be spiritual actually prevents you from being spiritual.
So it's,
it's the opposite that isn't going to see it.
Yeah.
Spirituality has so much to do at true humility.
Exactly.
And not worrying about your fucking image and the,
they're,
the real issue with fake spiritual is fake spirituality is that it's all about
the image.
It's all about projecting this artificial piety,
this artificial,
you know,
sense of,
it's like,
it's like vegans that get real uppity with you about Ken animals.
It's like what they're really doing is they're taking a moral high ground.
They're taking a ground,
they're taking,
whether it's a Christian ground or the spiritual ground,
they're pretending to be above you,
you know?
And they'll do it with this spirituality or there.
I think now that I've gotten down there,
I think anybody be in kind of like that.
She just have to prove it.
Just drink up full capa.
Iowasca we were in,
see what happens.
We were in 24 hour,
24 hour fitness and I was with Eddie Bravo back when he was in his most
ferocious,
there was a time when Eddie Bravo would just try to hit on every pretty girl he
could run into the Falcon days,
could not,
not hit on them.
Long history,
so bad motherfucker.
He was being successful.
So he was,
he was knocking them out of the park and just enjoying it.
But Anyway,
point is we're at a a gym and we're lifting weights in this girl and this cute
little body and she's talking to him and you know,
and Eddie is like,
so what's up?
You know,
where you from?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And she was like,
Oh,
I'm from out of state and I'm really not that happy with California.
And she was like real uppity.
And he's like,
what's up?
Like what's the matter?
She goes,
well,
you know what,
there's just a lack of spirituality here.
And I don't think that,
uh,
the men are very godlike.
That's what she actually said.
She actually said they're not very godlike.
And we were like,
and I know,
and I was like right there with them.
It was like,
she said like,
I want,
I don't want to start making fun of her,
but he says he's trying to get laid so I'm being cool.
And I back off and I'm like,
fuck,
Oh God.
And then we're over work it out.
And he goes,
she didn't say God's like the men are not God.
Like,
you know,
I guess what she was saying was like,
like living by the word of God.
Anyway,
long story short,
a week later we at the spearmint Rhino Strip club in Van Nuys,
California,
who takes the stage right in front of us,
but God like,
are you serious?
Like in the all nudes trip club with her hot little body.
We'll look at a right at our little asshole and she looks at us and the fucking
poor girl,
she remembered us from the gym and she remembered that that was the day that she
had probably chosen to try out this new persona.
You know,
crazy strippers.
One day they're super religious and one day they're fucking spiritual.
The next day they're going to be a yoga teacher.
Now they're fucking lost.
That's why they're stripping.
It wasn't God like,
like perfect body face,
everything like that.
Like not religious neither.
No,
no,
no.
She was,
no,
no.
It was clearly,
she was talking about spirituality first she said,
men aren't spiritual.
And then she said they're not very god.
Like she was talking about the people aren't spiritual in California and that
she's from a place where people are,
you know,
much more in tune with the way of God.
But it was hilarious.
Step clubs in the VAT,
the Nebraska
regular stroke code.
This shit is hard core.
This is a pussies and assholes in your face.
And she's,
you know,
equivalent or butt and doing that thing when they shake their butt up and down.
I'm like,
yeah,
but it's just God like,
anyway,
that's fig spiritual.
So you're in the jungle.
There's no fake spiritual people.
It's all genuine,
but it's,
it's like a very high percentage of really any hot chicks out there.
Um,
no,
not really.
There was some,
there was something that took care of themselves and,
and uh,
actually,
um,
I was able to go with my mother.
You went with your mother woke and sweet.
Cool.
Yeah.
It was one or two days.
That whole new,
a whole new world.
Really good mom.
Because she was a semifinalist and Wimbledon pro athlete.
Wow.
Traveled the world.
No Shit.
I know that for sure.
Wow,
that's amazing.
So she has a mobster gangster shit.
My mom would get annoying after a couple of days in Peru.
I could tell tough action.
My mom is somewhere along the lines,
become a five year old.
Explain everything to her mom.
That's fake is,
that's a commercial what?
She'll send me things and he,
can you believe this?
No,
I can't because it's not real.
It's Bruce Lee.
Have you seen this?
You know,
but I don't think it'd be down with going into the spirit world with her.
We were in a bus going off a cliff and I have no choice
then we're taking that trip together.
But until then,
so,
um,
you get down there with your mom,
you're on a canoe,
you don't know did and did you have to talk her into this?
Nah,
she was into it.
She was fired up.
So I think she was looking for,
she doesn't really have any strong kind of set beliefs,
but she's like a look of rabid explorer.
She loves new adventures and things like that.
So she knew I was into it and she's like,
yeah,
I'd love to do that.
So was she ever religious at all?
No,
not really now.
But she's,
you know,
she's just open to things,
but she has,
it doesn't really formed her own paradigm necessarily.
She knows enough to discard the bullshit monotheistic paradigm.
She's like,
all right,
that's not true.
But she hasn't really gone the other way to say like,
all right,
what else can I construct now?
Before she did this Iowasca trip,
did she have any psychedelic experiences,
like a bad acid trip back in college or something like that.
So pretty much did you talk or any of this or a little bit?
A little bit.
She was,
she was a bit nervous about that aspect of old your mom.
Um,
60 ish,
I should probably say
crazy,
but she was a,
you know,
they do a really good job when you get down explaining every one of the Shamans
we met,
I'm kinda jumping ahead in the story a bit,
but explaining how it's 100% medicine.
Like all of them,
they're like,
this is medicine.
You don't do this for fun.
You do this to cleanse your body,
to cleanse your organs.
You purge it and it shows you things you know,
and there's a wisdom to it.
It's a hundred percent medicine and they get really offended when you call it a
drug,
you know,
to them it's a medicine.
It's the master medicine.
Like you said,
it's the medicine that they believe has helped them find all other medicines in
the jungle.
You know,
they take the IOWASCA,
they go in and that's how they find their other cures and all of these
showman's,
these veggie least as I WASC is just one part of it.
But it's to them,
that's their master sacred medicine.
So
I lost her so bad ass.
So they don't give a fuck about mushrooms.
Yeah.
Schamens likes playing with that shit for sure.
We playing with that shit for it.
Yeah.
You're going to see some crazy ass take symbols and you don't need put that down
and have a drink of this.
Yeah.
But you know what they do say?
They say,
you know you can't always get Iowasca so they recommend that mushroom is when
you can,
I have every every two months they're like every two months you better do
something and if you've got mushrooms,
great
every two months you should be setting.
That's a good segue because they say you need to hit that reset button,
reconnect with the earth mother.
And you know that kind of,
which of them is just a representation of the the Yin side,
that kind of every two months,
nature side of the house.
I've had some DMT experiences that were so intense.
I took years off.
I was just like,
Whoa,
I need to think about this.
But DMT,
the orally active version is much slower and more gradual and you can kind of
tune in and out of it.
You can get in the meditative state when it's full blown or as it's slipping
away,
you can get right back in there if you relax and tune into it.
If you're a warrior,
if you're a warrior.
But if it's crap,
if you're a career,
if you're cracked,
it's gonna fucking destroy you was,
yeah,
I'll get into that in the story.
But you have to know who you are.
You do before you start fucking with this stuff.
It's happy.
They call it the vine of death.
You know,
that's the sign of the souls,
right?
Finding the soles are vying to death.
Find Out Death,
Huh?
Yeah.
Okay.
Swipe though.
So first night,
did they give you a little baby dose and see if everybody should know how it go?
You know,
we get in,
we get assigned a roommate.
I ended up with a lucky one.
He was willing mate.
Yeah,
we got to write an extra to have your own tent.
Not on this one.
They didn't have the room.
Listen Bro,
I'll give you 50 coconuts.
Just give me my fucking 10 yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
But I'm that guy.
Yeah.
So he was,
he was cool.
He was an old Israel.
There are no suites here.
He's an old Israeli guys,
old Israeli tank commander in water polo stuff.
They all know pay to be hanging out with.
Yeah.
The only other guy that was like,
I was like,
God,
I got lucky.
Like this is fucking sweet.
He was a cool dude.
I,
I'm still in touch with them.
Oh Wow.
Wade and me and him were the most different out of it.
Everybody else in the whole group,
everybody else was definitely,
you know,
not,
as I said,
not the saltiest bunch you've got to bring out.
Wow.
Okay.
So Do,
do they slowly let you dip your feet in the barn as you in and uh,
and
they announced the three Shamans,
they flown in the three best schamens improve basically,
uh,
from different camps,
different parts of the jungle.
One is local to where they're at.
So it's like a battle of the DJ's this exactly.
And you choose which one you want to work with.
So they announced the first one a long lineage of what he's done and he kind of
integrate some of the Christian saints with some of the Iowasca work,
works with the masculine aspects as a big bio of all he's accomplished.
So it's like,
all right,
whatever,
but I'm not really going to be into the,
you know,
kind of mixing of the Christian ideal.
So wait for the second guy,
he has his own psychology clinic and then in the jungle and he's helped build
this hospital and blah,
blah,
another big long thing.
And he sings he sweet songs and then they get to the third guy.
And,
uh,
the third guy,
they say only say he's the most traditional and the most terrifying.
He calls upon the spirit of the dragon and that's it.
That's all I said.
And I was like,
does my gods,
my guy,
that's all he said about him.
That's all I said about less is more people.
It's a Clint Eastwood approach to shamanism.
Yup.
Exactly.
So,
okay.
So um,
it was just the first night,
the first night they go right into it.
Right into it.
Wow.
Okay.
So Day one,
they won't pull up in a canoe.
What time do you actually get to the campus?
It knew about three 30,
three 30 in the afternoon.
Do you eat first or no,
eat.
We ate,
we ate right then at three 30,
but then that's it.
No dinner.
Right.
Cause the ceremony starts at eight 30.
Okay.
So they recommend five hours.
That's it.
To purge your system.
I thought it was like,
well they will ask for 12.
Um,
this one they didn't,
you know,
but the food that they're serving is like jungle food,
it's like light.
It's clean,
it's all grown out there.
They eat.
What kind of food?
A lot of vegetables.
A lot Chenwa.
Um,
they had some,
you know,
like fresh free range chicken and a lot of tilapia type of fish,
things like that.
Like really kind of light and the catching everything in their cells.
Yeah.
Wow.
So um,
yeah you eat,
you sit around and just wait for the party began on my roommate and kind of wait
for it and then they talk about a little bit and then you have a few minutes to
kind of gather yourself and get ready for the uh,
and maybe like rolling it all day.
These guys brought it from their homes so they brew it in their home,
so each each,
so he didn't mind.
They don't,
you don't get to watch them now they have to boil it,
boil one,
boil the other,
mix it.
But it was my has their own secret perfect recipe that they've learned from
Taiwan.
I would want to see them cook it because after the movie altered states,
that was one of the trippiest parts.
When the guy was cooking up to shit,
I want to see them cook it.
Like you can't just pull it out of a fucking Tupperware container for me,
man.
I want to see it cook it.
I actually,
there's a video I posted on my blog kind of midway down on a warrior poet.us
that has actually the meister that I work with and it shows some pictures of
them boiling it with the big sticks.
And it has like a big cast iron pots to put up two different pots brewing side
by side one with the leaf,
I think in one with a,
with a vice,
a long ass time,
right?
Yeah.
It's not quite,
it takes like 10 hours or something to make.
Okay.
So,
um,
they sit you down and how do they determine the dosage?
Well,
it's,
it's an eyeball test from the shotgun.
So we walk in,
we,
I have,
I have by the fewest people with our group because people were scared of the
dragon and it denying,
so I had like 10 people,
so we don't have a small hut and the secluded part of the jungle.
So along walk my,
uh,
my fearless compatriots were kind of laughing and joking around and I felt
confident,
but I was very calm.
I knew I was going into some pretty intense work,
you know,
so,
um,
we had it,
we get in there and then,
you know,
they do some of the opening ceremony of
k.
Dot.
So all of us are faced like spokes of a wheel towards the center of the room
and we all have a puke bucket kind of near us because,
you know,
most people purge during this process.
It's part of the healing process.
And then,
uh,
he calls us up one by one,
kind of looks,
you know,
looks at you who assesses and then pours a coconut,
the pours the Iowasca and like a polished coconut husk and uh,
and you drink and it is,
it is thick and bitter and just tastes like earth in like Derek fire.
They're like,
it's,
it's tough.
I mean it's,
it's tough to go down.
I mean,
it's very thick.
And did everyone drinking?
Did anybody did at once?
You're in the ceremony,
you got to drink.
No,
no.
Observers know,
peeping toms on the action there.
Does the showman get in as well?
He does.
He but he drinks,
he drinks kind of steadily throughout the thing.
He doesn't,
you know,
he's kind of always drinking and always cause that's how he creates his,
his world that he's
so by creating his world,
he's not just concocting the,
the formula.
He's also beating a drum and blowing cigar,
smoke tobacco smoke.
And what is he doing?
Yeah,
so what,
you know,
30 minutes.
It was just silence in there.
And then he starts what's called is ecos and the Ikaros or his songs and the
songs that was taught to him by his grandfather who,
you know,
they trace it back,
grandfather to father a man.
I couldn't do it,
but it can Trussell let's pull one up.
Can we pull one number?
Can we play on that?
It's like,
yeah.
I mean it's a,
it starts with ECO rose.
How do you spell eco?
Ross?
I C.
A.
R.
O.
S.
Iowasca.
ICAROS.
Yeah.
You know how to spell Iowasca?
A y.
Yeah.
Well,
I want to hear some of that shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hold on a second.
Get one of those and we'll play it on the background while he's talking to,
it'll be trippy as fuck.
So this cat has his own separate eco roast and the other two gentlemen have
their own,
and they have female Shamans as well,
right?
Yeah.
Not here.
They do,
but not the IOWASCA arrows in the vegetal east does.
It's,
it's kind of a very paternalistic,
you know,
could,
it's not a heritage,
a male dominated.
It's not about like priests,
right?
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's very,
I mean,
they worship higher than anything is the earth mother.
So it just happens to seem that the men,
um,
where the maestros in this case,
there's female Shamans for sure.
They call them don't onions.
My ester us.
Um,
and we,
I was actually one in the,
uh,
but she wasn't an Ios Garrow necessarily.
She was just a more General Sharman.
But she was,
she was smart too,
and she was strong.
You got something to,
dude,
what are you doing?
Would that be it?
Oh,
let's hear it.
It's too many instruments in there obviously,
but they use just like a whistle in their voice.
It's like,
did you uh,
look up eco rose?
That's just Iowasca right.
Put it that press,
you know,
enter right.
Copy that shit.
And then right eco rose.
I see.
Yeah.
That'll get you a R.
Yeah.
Let me hear some craziness.
Aw,
Fuck John Tesh present.
Judge
Kenny G.
Maybe it was a acre rose over that shitty music.
Yeah,
it sounds more like,
yeah,
my guy didn't sound like that.
He was a lot more basketball.
Fine Buck.
Um,
yeah,
that's it.
Okay.
So he only has,
his tools are,
he has his breath,
but you use this more than anything.
And then he has a,
he has a kind of a branch with a bunch of leaves that he uses this sort of like
a rattle and those are his tools in his voice and his listening.
So,
and he also has some cinnamon sticks,
which you choose at the end.
But I'll get,
I'll get to that.
This is tripping me out.
Put me back in
back there.
You're going to change your name back to Chris.
Okay.
So how long does it take after you drink it?
About 45 minutes.
You start to feel people rustling 30 to 45 minutes.
It's hard.
I mean it's cave dark.
You don't have a perfect perception of time,
but 30 to 45 minutes,
people start to rustle.
It starts to activate.
How big is this came this,
uh,
um,
probably 20 foot in diameter.
So it's tight,
tight quarters for 10 people.
So it starts going and you know,
you start to get that energetic activation,
same as you do on mushrooms or something where you know something's about to
happen,
you're closed.
I had visuals start to splash with color and light and things like that.
Um,
your stomach starts to Gurgle a little bit and then uh,
so that was happening and he started as he cross,
you know,
starts slowly,
kind of like it is now whistling and building,
building.
And then,
you know,
at about an hour you here,
the first person just Rach like Ahhh.
And it's not like just a gentle bullying style.
This is like years of rock just pouring out of every organ that they have and
their,
it's their half yelling,
half puking when they do it.
I mean he's like,
ah.
So it's not just the,
the medicine coming up.
There's like a,
yeah,
like a sacrifice or expelling mio and things out of your,
out of your organs.
I didn't Puke till the second paradigm shifting session,
but you either goes out your,
you know,
you vomit or finds another motive evacuation.
But it's,
you can feel it works.
A lot of people shit themselves too.
Is that what you're saying?
It wouldn't be,
yeah,
it has the Tanner,
they just shit themselves at all.
And I'll explain all play Israeli guy.
He was in a,
he was in a different session actually that time,
so I wasn't there.
But anyway,
so the first people start to purge and then pretty soon after that you smell
farts.
It was,
yeah,
it was just chaos erupts in the room.
We all Michael Pants,
like one of the,
one of the ladies just turn into a blithering child.
I'm like,
help me,
help me.
But another person started pretending that he could sing the gross,
but it was like a kid that thinks he knows the words to a song.
She was like two beats off and it was awful.
And then another lady completely lost her internal monologue.
And this culminated throughout the night and her finally saying,
I can't tell if I shit my pants or if I didn't shit my pants like over and over
again.
And I was like,
Oh God,
you know,
I mean,
this is so people,
people who weren't ready cracked,
you know,
bad.
I mean it wasn't,
that's not the experience you're supposed to get.
You're supposed to keep it to yourself,
follow through to interfere with your thoughts though on homeless.
Throw you off that a little bit freaking out.
But it was,
it was two pounds.
And knowing that part,
that part was rough in this first,
in this first session.
And then,
you know,
right as I'm starting to get,
get some serious visions.
Lady next to me and I'd like shuttered and she puked all over my socks.
So they pitch black and I'm peeling off the wet chunky wool from my feet and put
him on the side and just curl back up on my map.
No way to clean it.
It's fucking pitch black or in the middle of the ceremony starting to trip
balls.
So that was,
that was the start of it.
Um,
and it was kind of signatory for the way the rest of the night went because it
was intense and dark.
And uh,
you know,
what started happening is snake started coming in through the jungle.
I had visions of snakes and they would look at me and then immediately start
savagely like going inside my body and like eating my organs,
eating my throat,
like going down my throat and eating their way out and like exploding through my
body.
And I know enough from psychedelic experiences to just witness and allow and
just let it happen.
You know?
Cause if you try and fight it,
you're fucked.
You're fucked.
You can't,
that is the number one reason why people have bad trips.
Yeah.
They tried to control the experience.
But did you think these snakes were real or did you know they were kind of like,
I was cool with this at this point and then it switched.
Yeah.
Cool.
Just think blasting.
I kind of knew that the vine and death was going to take me there.
I had a feeling that these snakes,
do they look like real snakes or do you know that's a fucking real snake?
I'm actually getting eaten by a jungle snake right now.
No,
they were more like,
um,
there were a bit a femur or you know,
they would change too much in color and the way that they would come was not
necessarily slithering on the ground.
They were coming from the air and they all top hats on snakes.
Lou,
they look like a lot of them,
a lot of them were,
were kind of white.
They were,
they looked actually the more like boas or con or like anacondas not,
not as much like domestic snakes that we'd find out here,
but they had that kind of jungle pattern.
But they would,
you know,
the colors were off.
They were not,
they were either too colorful or they're,
or they're white.
They weren't like jungle colors,
but they were that shape and that size of these things.
Um,
so like you're tuning into it but not totally correctly.
Like as if you're on a station and the colors are all off and the fucking,
the cop outfit is white instead of blue.
It's like in that skin is blue instead of white.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
um,
so that was going on and then after I,
you know,
got used to that,
then it switched and I kept sliding down these binds of thorns that were just
ripping me up to pieces.
Again,
all of these images were just total destruction of the flesh and know you
feeling anything while this is happening,
you're kind of a passive observer of your,
uh,
of your body,
seeing it in a third person or yet outside of your body,
about two feet,
about two feet outside of your body as you're watching this happen to you.
So you're like looking down on it.
Yeah,
kind of like,
you know,
up here on your shoulder a bit and just destruction,
destruction.
And I was,
you know,
I remember thinking myself because I was naked when this was happening.
I was like,
why did I have to be naked in this thing?
But that's just the way it was.
It just me naked flash,
just getting torn slide.
And what do you see seen blood and injuries and yeah,
you do.
You see it all.
I mean just liquid pouring out of your body.
It's just complete destruction of the physical form.
And then,
and then from there,
you know,
insects would burrow into my body and explode and the cheese,
the spiders and things would go.
And really that was not,
that was not so bad actually.
I though that was kind of a good part.
But what,
what Iowasca will do is it will find your own weaknesses and then use them to
fuck with you.
It's like when you're at the final level of a video game and it's like,
no,
you must fight yourself.
You know,
like that's what it felt like.
So it started praying on my own fears and I heard a voice telling me exactly
what I was scared of,
which is,
you know,
some,
some illness,
my family's had some lymphoma,
my shoes or something like that.
So it basically said,
you're going to die of cancer,
you know,
say your goodbyes,
you're fucking done.
You got it.
Now it's bad.
You know?
And it was telling me that and that actually started to shake me a little bit,
you know,
because I've never had it work against myself,
work against me in that kind of magnitude.
You know,
I've had visions of things before that were dark and I always worked through and
it,
you know,
I ended up feeling good,
but that was a more challenging experience in.
And then at a certain point,
you know,
I had to just apply the same philosophy and say,
you know what,
if this is the end,
I'm gonna have a fucking hell of a six months,
you know,
and I'm going to do everything I can and enjoy my life and then boom,
that ended.
And then finally at that point I was able to get a sense of peace and I felt
myself getting sucked back down into the earth.
Kind of like in the,
the only thing I can describe is that movie Avatar,
you know,
in the little fibers grow up around the body and it like connects it back down
to the earth.
I felt this deep relaxation just like right back down into the earth.
And then,
um,
you know,
that was kind of the end.
That was the climax of this first experience for me.
Did you get a sense that it was a purposeful trip?
The only reason why they,
it takes you on this destruction of your body and the snakes and everything like
that.
Is it supposed to scare the fuck out of you to break you down?
It's,
it's supposed to.
It's a death rebirth motif really is what it is.
And uh,
you know,
that was the idea of the medicine and the night each,
each night the medicine had a theme and the first night it was Anaconda medicine
snake medicine,
which is shedding your skin in one piece.
So like a snake does it,
snake sheds its skin all in one piece.
This was about shedding everything that you don't need,
your fears,
your weaknesses,
all of that.
And that's why you explore it.
And I think part of the intent of what the Shaman was doing,
which meanwhile by the way is as we're growing and intensity and it was like the
room was swirling with a voice.
You have a CD,
like a mixed tape.
I would love to see that.
He has a youtube video,
which I bought some,
I bought some Ikaros online once,
listened to it for five minutes and it wasn't high enough and I shut her off.
He has a website.
Uh,
he does,
he does.
He has a youtube video.
What does he have?
A website,
which is website.
Oh Man.
I,
I couldn't tell it was,
it's in Spanish,
you know,
so I can't recall it on the top of my head.
Maestro Orlando to [inaudible]
Hospital,
last name,
c.
U.
H.
C H.
U.
C h.
J.
A n.
A N d.
A.
M.
And it's also,
Brian,
if you bring it up on my blog,
you can probably get the direct link discovery of the eight dimension.
Yeah,
that's May's could journey.
That's me.
It is you.
Yeah.
Is this a video that you made?
That was a video I made.
I'll tell about that was my second,
just while you were in there.
Oh Dude,
you have video?
Yeah.
Okay.
Go to warrior,
poet us on Youtube and check out this video.
That's hilarious.
You're the number one hit on the fucking,
on this guy's name.
It's you and the tent tripping your balls off.
Yeah.
This was the second session.
You look terrified.
It takes me a while.
It takes me a while to get through it.
Don't,
don't jump to that video til I get to the party.
Let's talk.
Let's not play that video.
I want to hear all this shit.
So,
so,
um,
so yeah,
so that,
you know,
that first experience.
So after he comes by,
the Shaman comes by.
He asked me,
I'll call my mustache.
I say,
uh,
you know,
I managed to muster something like [inaudible].
I told him I was dead.
Good and dead.
And he just laughed and,
and kind of that was,
I think when we,
you know,
he started to kind of give me a little bit of respect because the rest of the
room was just crushed,
you know,
but I,
I was crushed too,
but at least,
you know,
I was able to sit up and,
and uh,
and Kinda deal with it a little bit.
So,
um,
he brings me over this to where he's at and he,
uh,
he starts chewing up some cinnamon and it's the final closing ceremony in the
cleansing ritual and he has me open the back of my shirt and he goes,
sure.
With the cinnamon and the instant he did that,
it was like I was on a bungee cord and just,
and this is six hours after I'd taken it,
you know,
my,
the peak of my trip was completely done and I just went straight up and right
into this world of just pure energetic vibration that I had no idea how to
decode.
It was something completely foreign to anything I've ever seen.
What did he do with the cinnamon?
So he chews it up.
He's like cinnamon six dried cinnamon,
right.
And then he blows his breath.
He goes sure.
And forums,
like a little sonic missile thing.
And he put the points that at different parts of your different parts of it,
like the back of your neck,
the top of your head.
So he did it four times and each time he did it,
I had like 10 seconds swimming in this world that just,
I had no possible chance that decode.
And it was unbelievable.
I was like,
what the hell is this?
Where am I?
You know,
how do I understand it?
What does it mean?
You know,
like the youtube video.
But it was wild on that closing part of the ceremony.
So what did,
what did it mean you can't decide?
You coded?
Can you describe,
it was like a geometrical city of light and vibration,
you know?
But it was like,
it was like looking at,
imagine if you didn't know anything about computer code and you looked at the
matrix,
right?
And all you saw were ones and zeroes.
Right?
Now we know,
oh that's computer code.
It's source code.
It was like that kind of information was coming to me,
but I just,
you know what,
that sounds like a DMT trip.
Yeah.
So you have a flash,
you have a DMT flash,
so like in deep into another blowing cinnamon on you.
And that's what causes that.
Yeah,
I dunno if the cinnamon is just to make the,
his blood,
his breath pleasant and it's as intent or whether it actually has some part of
it or distract you while some guy has a needle in the back of your neck and just
jam oily.
Lobotomizing no,
but it was,
you know,
whatever he did in that closing part of it,
it,
I felt like it opened a breach in something else.
A different place for 10 seconds,
for 10 seconds,
then suck back as soon as soon as that was over,
I was right back.
You know,
wouldn't laugh.
Okay.
So this is day one they want,
so then do you get up in the morning?
Do you go to bed?
Go to bed?
Yeah,
show off to Puke.
yeah,
yeah.
So I went,
you know,
took care of everything in the,
in the,
in the dark,
in my hot and the dark.
Yeah.
It cold and dark.
There's no light at all.
No light at no candles are using our phones and flashlights and they have the
charger for your phone.
Um,
three hours a day.
You can charge it for three hours a day.
Yeah.
So you're using your phone,
you know,
getting service.
So it's just a flashlight,
a little flashlight,
expensive iPhone,
flashlight.
All right,
so you wash yourself off.
Yeah.
Crash out and you sleep.
I did fucking freaking out while you're sleeping and you slept good.
I felt pretty good,
you know,
after that final thing where I was able to relax and felt sucked back into the
earth,
um,
I felt good.
You know,
I felt like I learned the importance of the physical realm.
You know what I mean?
See,
next day breakfast is,
do people apologize
for throwing out money?
Yeah.
Some people were still,
some people are still pretty,
pretty shocked.
Like the people in my group were pretty shocked.
A lot of them didn't go back.
Some of them didn't do it again.
The whole,
it's really,
yeah.
I mean they,
they weren't,
they fought it.
They fought the whole time.
And if you fight the whole time,
you never release from it.
You know,
you don't work through it.
It's like you get brought to the heat of the battle and then you just ignore it
and shut your eyes and it goes away.
But it sticks with you.
And that's,
that's one thing that,
you know,
a caution for doing any kind of psychedelic work is you've got to work through
it.
So for her it was a very,
she just had very repetitive visions.
Um,
you know,
I was surprised that it didn't take her deeper,
but she was working with some of the lighter,
lighter doses in the lighter schamens.
Um,
and they could tell that she was,
the way that they dose.
He was pretty smart.
Usually they try and dose you to what,
you know,
what they think you can handle.
So,
but she was great.
She's,
it seems to me that just jumping right into an IOWASCA trip without any previous
psychedelic experiences like taking no martial arts classes and fighting in the
UFC,
it just seems ridiculous.
I wouldn't,
you want to build your way up slowly and smoke some Salvia eat a Brownie,
you know,
slowly legs into the river.
That is the second dog experience cause the,
the Iowasca experience in DMT experiences is supposed to be the two most
powerful that you can never have back to back.
You know,
one being a bit more on the spiritual side of the Iowasca that's supposedly
because it's longer and not as intense that it sort of connects you in a way
that you can interpret better than the DMT flash.
Yeah,
the DMT flash a lot of times just so mind bogglingly alien that it's,
there's no words for it.
You come back with a lot of confusion.
Like there's some message in it somewhere,
but it takes a while to decode.
I talked to them about smoking DMT as well.
And I'll get to that when I get,
I kind of have to set up kind of the paradigm first and then I'll tell you what
they said about smoking DMT versus taking ios.
So did you go right back in the second day?
Second day,
no.
Second day I just rested,
wrote in my journal,
made sure to kind of digest the,
you know,
what I had gone through.
It's very energetically taxing,
but I felt fucking great.
Like I felt reborn,
like energetic.
I slept five hours and I was just pumped.
Like I got a good workout in and I felt more alive than I have been in a long
time.
It was rad.
Like I felt my body felt great,
my mind felt great,
my spirit felt great.
I felt like I learned some valuable lessons about,
you know,
the d importance of the physical realm and I feel like I conquered some deep
fears about cancer and shit that was going on.
Like it was it like I'm not worried about that anymore.
Like it took me there to overcome it.
And you know,
really that first night for me was,
you know,
I,
I call it my death.
It was like the old parts of me that night died,
you know,
anything week,
uh,
was killed off by the IOWASCA.
But it's funny you said that,
you know,
the UFC analogy I wrote in my blog,
it was like,
it was like I was kind of with a bunch of karate,
black belts and you know,
they took Iowasca and just got punched the face.
I was like,
why the hell is going on here?
You know?
And they didn't really,
they had the training,
but it's different when you're in a street fight,
you know?
And that's uh,
that's kind of what it was.
I didn't have the training,
but I've been in a few brawls in my day.
So I think that that ends up being a bit more important,
um,
as far as being able to handle the experience.
But then,
you know,
at another point,
the second night,
I wish I did have some of their training cause I got an opportunity to do some
cool shit.
But I just didn't know what to do.
So without that,
so that's the second session I go up to them.
This is the third day,
slightly more comfortable room.
Um,
the people who from the first session,
a lot of them ducked out,
you know,
but there was new people who like wanted a strong experience.
So his legend started to spread in the camp.
So we had a few more people,
probably 15.
Um,
and I went up to him beforehand and I said,
you know,
my stress at a medicine,
a flat Earth Day,
like exercise,
like I wanted a strong dose and he looks at me and he smiled and he remembered
that I handled the last one pretty well.
So when it was my turn to go up,
you fills the cup to the brim,
like to the Brim and uh,
you know,
look at it and set my intent.
My intent was to see how far I could go.
Like I wanted to go back to that place.
He showed me at the end of the session and I wanted to experience joy and
happiness and that side of life the opposite side.
And just see where it could take me.
And that was really my goal in doing that.
And I picked up some tips from some of the other shamans about how to set kind
of your own spiritual armor and kind of prevent things from interfering and
taking you off your intent.
So I was like,
I felt well equipped,
drank the full cup three gulps,
pretty brutal again.
And then,
uh,
then it starts and it starts,
you know,
kind of similarly as usual.
Um,
you know,
an hour in visions,
things that I remember,
you know,
kind of like a psych,
most psychedelic trips are like,
ah,
I got to remember that.
That's a good lesson,
you know,
take little gems from the visions you see,
things like that.
Uh,
at some point some eels came out of the water and they started coming after me
and it was much like the snakes and I looked at the eels and,
uh,
I,
you know,
was able to kind of mentally stop them with the armor,
which was a trick,
you know,
opening your winner.
Coccia it's called.
Um,
and I was like,
oh,
sweet.
They stopped.
And I was like,
what's up?
He feels like this is not the day for killing me.
And I just told them that and they like looked at me and they're like,
yeah,
okay,
I'll believe you and just bounced.
And I was like,
sweet,
I'm not going to die today.
Like that's awesome.
They leave and what does it leave you with?
Well then where are you?
Yeah.
So then from there then from there things,
um,
things got,
that's when things got started to get crazy.
Like immediately the sensation of my head just peeling off the top of my head
happens.
And Joe,
I've been in fucking a lot of situations and done some shit.
Nothing,
nothing,
nothing could compare to how this felt.
It felt like every cell in neuron in my brain was completely sinked in perfect
alignment and glowing radioactive.
And I had no top of my head on,
it was like wall wall.
I mean it was on real as foreign to me as any sensation and it was a physical
sensation.
It wasn't a mental sensation.
I could physically feel my brain like alive from back from my brainstem all the
way to the frontal lobe,
like every part of it was full.
And I was like,
Whoa,
Shit.
Like something's happening here.
Like this is new,
this is a new ball game.
Right.
And what happened from them?
So from then,
um,
right after that happened,
you know,
I started to feel really fucking good,
like really good and,
and I was looking around the room and people were vomiting and lots of chaos.
It started around the room,
but I felt it all is like a kind of like just a cleanse,
you know,
like I had a different perspective on it.
So each one would bring me more like happiness until finally it reached this
ecstatic state,
which was about 10 minutes of just pure,
straight ecstasy.
Like every cell of my body felt better than it ever had before.
It was like the exact reason why we're given physical forms was do experience
some kind of pleasure like this.
The only thing I compare it to.
And every time I make this analogy,
people ask if I nodded my pants,
which I didn't,
but it felt like that moment of orgasm stretched for like five minutes,
10 minutes.
Like I didn't know where that a yell.
It was like so crazy,
intensely bodily good to feel that.
And then,
you know,
so experience that and that was rad.
I was like,
you know,
that would have been enough right there.
But then it just continued to build.
And so what happened next is this giant organic flotilla of like snakes and
feathers comes like a China.
Kind of like an organic mothership comes and it hovers over my head.
And these,
this is full open eyed visuals,
right?
How big is this?
Oh man,
it was probably 30 yards.
40 yards.
Big 30 yards.
Yeah,
it was big.
It was a massive things.
Feathers and snake,
Heather's and snakes and it's living,
it's a living,
it's like a living mothership.
Right.
And it starts sucking black smoke out of my body and I see it coming out and I
was like,
oh well I guess I guess I didn't need that.
I was like,
okay,
take it,
you know,
like cool.
And it didn't have any physical sensation but I could see it like coming out of
my body.
It came out of my throat,
came out of my head,
came out of,
you know,
different parts.
I guess you could correspond them to the,
to the shockers where they were coming out,
but just peeling out of my body.
I was like,
Whoa,
that's pretty cool.
And then it just floats off when the smoke started to die off.
And then right on its heels,
another mothership comes and this mothership is metallic and it has all kinds of
crazy cryptic riding on it.
Like stargate,
Sgi type of writing.
It's the only thing I can compare.
Your eyes are open when you fully and how does it look real?
Can you see through it?
Does it look like in an illusion?
No,
you can't see through it.
You couldn't,
I couldn't see anything else really,
honestly.
I,
it was,
it was black around it.
I,
my memory of it is that I could just see that and that was it.
I think if I tried to like focus back on,
you know,
my own reality,
I could see some shit in the room,
but then that's all I could,
it was black and it was a ship and that was,
that was the only thing I was focused on.
So it looked like an alien spacecraft stay staff fully.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
No,
very much like that.
Very much like this shit not quite that big and there's writing on it something,
it wasn't just smooth,
you know what I mean?
It wasn't like a smooth thing.
It was either writing or a very cool design.
I Dunno.
I mean I had no hope to read it or anything,
but so then it,
and then it starts shooting this light at me and this was one of the craziest
things.
Like,
as soon as the light comes,
I like lift my head up like this and open,
open,
like put the,
put my tongue on the roof of my mouth and the light starts coming in underneath
my Tom.
I don't know why I did.
I have no fucking clue why I did that.
But I did it and that's what I needed to do.
And I was just started doing it.
I was like breathing in this light.
It was like I was getting uploaded some kind of information again,
no physical sensation,
but I'm just,
you know,
just breathing in,
breathing in this white light that's being uploaded into me.
And then I was like,
whoa,
this is fucking crazy.
You know?
And I couldn't believe that I knew that that was what I was supposed to do and,
but I just did it.
And then the light stops,
boom,
retracts ship goes away.
And then that,
at that point,
everything just blew out like the,
I saw the room again and then the room just goes,
blows out into infinity and just complete infinity around me.
Now there's a couple things in infinity.
There's the Shaman who's like jutted out on a precipice,
who's going pretty hard with his he cross now.
Um,
and then there's like some terraform.
It wasn't Halloween.
Oh Man,
if you listened to his video,
he's,
he sings it a little bit.
But I wish I could get you something.
But it's
knee Jeannine and 18 nae nae,
nae,
Nae,
Nae Nae.
Now the other words or is it just knows and sometimes there is some,
it's like I lost.
I mean,
you know,
sometimes those things and things like that.
So that's kind of a flight.
Ravi said I have a terrible voice.
He didn't have a great voice either,
but it was powerful.
You know what I mean?
It's not like he was a singer,
it was just coming out and he was shaking is shaking his leaves.
But he's jotted up on this precipice.
And that was at three o'clock in my line of vision,
nine o'clock there some kind of terra forma and kind of universal stars and,
but it was like boom,
like everything,
everything else was completely gone.
Everything else I could see kind of vague outlines and white light.
You just got a software update.
Yeah,
for sure.
But this is the fucking,
this is another crazy factor.
I would turn my head to the left,
you know,
turned my head 90 degrees and still the Shamans at three o'clock,
the terraform is at nine o'clock.
It did not matter which way I turned my head.
I could lie down,
I could go left,
I could go right.
Didn't matter.
My vision was stuck in the same spot.
It's like any movements I made in the third dimension had absolutely no impact
of what I was seeing in the eight dimension.
Like I guess if I wanted to look around in that dimension,
why is it the eighth time?
So I'll get to that.
Sorry about that.
But that's,
that's,
that was what I encountered in,
so that's,
that's the paradigm they used at the end of it.
They call,
you know,
they call where I was at that point,
the eighth dimension.
And,
and the reason why is,
um,
that's the penultimate dimension.
That's the last one before the ninth,
which is oneness with all creation,
which is just,
you know,
unification with,
with all life,
all creation that ever was,
that ever will be pure solidarity with,
uh,
with,
with God,
with the universe,
whatever.
Is that supposed to be what you're hitting when he blows the cinnamon smoke now.
So that was actually the seventh dimension is what they were going,
but to go back to where I,
where I was,
where I was there,
and I'll explain that the paradigm as they see,
they give you a map of each question they do afterwards,
tourists good afterwards.
So,
um,
so yeah,
so at that,
at that point,
no visions were coming.
Nothing was happening to me at all and I was completely lucid.
So I was like,
all right,
what can I do?
And I was thinking like,
well,
what would I want to do?
I was like,
well,
I got a friend who got in a car wreck.
I was like,
I wonder how he's doing and he's in Atlanta.
And so I was like,
wonder how he's doing?
Boom.
I see him and he's in like a bar or restaurant and I'm like,
Oh snap.
Like he just came immediately.
It didn't have to travel.
Like I could see it right there.
And he's laughing,
talking with friends.
I was like,
well it looks like he's okay,
but I wonder if he really is.
And I was able to like look in his body and I see this like bad energetic,
something like this black part of in his rib cage.
And I was like,
oh that's,
that's no good.
And I was like,
I wonder if I can get rid of that.
then I focused on pushing like white,
that golden light into his body and I was like,
Bill's his body and pushes this little missile out of his ribs.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
Like I don't know if that actually helped them,
but that was pretty rad that I was able to do it.
You know?
I didn't know I got to call him up afterwards.
I couldn't call.
There's no,
there's no cell phone talking to him later.
I talked to him later.
He doesn't remember like the exact moment,
but he said right around then.
Yeah,
he started feeling way better,
you know,
so,
um,
I don't know.
Then before that I just,
you know,
he had,
he had a bad impact,
got t bone with some lady coming off the,
off the freeway,
hit the steering wheel,
hit his head.
So he felt better out of nowhere.
Did you ask him,
hey man,
do you ever been in a bar and then all of a sudden you feel better?
Or did you say,
Hey,
I did some food freaky Voodoo on you?
Did you put the power of suggestion and it's fine when you,
sadly,
next time I talked to him,
I was fucking hammered.
So I think we just got right into it.
It wasn't like you got to dance around that one.
Find out the real evidence.
I know.
No.
So,
um,
next time,
next time I'll do that.
But we,
you know,
he just breezed into town and I was like,
Yo,
I'm just back from Peru.
Um,
but anyway,
so,
so I didn't get the proper scientific explanation,
but some loose correlation with how it works.
Okay.
But more concrete evidence on myself.
Um,
I was like,
all right,
well if I do that to him,
what about myself?
And I started scanning my body with my,
with my hands and my mind and it was like a car mechanic looking at the car,
like I was completely detached from and I was like,
oh that's pretty good.
Like I did a pretty good job here.
Like that's not bad.
Like this vessel is pretty good.
And I was just giving it like a 10 point inspection and you know,
my glands that have always been swollen,
I was like,
ah,
there's something not quite right there.
So I like went and I like physically like started pulling out of out of my
glands.
It was like,
well maybe I can pull what's bad out of there.
And I felt like I did and I felt like it stuck to my fingers and my shaking my
fingers like,
ah,
get it off.
I didn't know how to get it off.
So I like shake it and some of it falls off and then I put it in the ground and
some of it like drips off.
And then I was like,
oh,
it's still not working.
So I had a water then and I poured it on my fingers and that seemed to work.
Um,
you know,
who knows,
who knows about that.
But since then I haven't gotten,
my glands have not been swollen at all and I've gotten like Epstein Barr virus
that always like has him a little bit swollen,
but not even a bit since then.
So I dunno
now.
Whoa,
thank God you weren't just ripping your face off at that time by the way.
Oh,
I was so lucid,
like anything I thought.
And then I was like,
well what am I listening to?
What you just said?
You said I was so lucid my glands out.
Yeah,
I was ripping my glands.
Now we're dirt.
It's weird,
right?
Shooting long missiles out of your friend when you hear us
dump like this,
you know when you hear yourself say it,
who's phone is that?
Someone's got their phone right next to the thing
anyway.
You hear that shit,
that feedback that's a phone next to something.
Anyway.
Um,
when,
when you hear yourself saying this knee's hear yourself describing it,
it's surely part of,
you must think how preposterous and ridiculous.
This must sound to a skeptical person.
Sure.
Like,
you know,
a skeptical,
no nonsense.
Sort of a fucking gold water Republican listened to this Faggot Shit.
You know,
you listen to this ridiculous nonsense.
He's fucking pussy kids.
Wait,
you want to find yourself?
Huh?
You want to find yourself?
Yeah,
go off.
Not On jumbo and take drugs.
That's how you find yourself.
I mean,
you must,
he must think,
I mean like listen to,
you know,
this is like,
this is like the main thing that people would criticize.
You know,
if they would hear about people trying to find themselves with drugs.
Yeah.
This fucking idiot thinks he's pulling cancer out of it.
Blends.
Yeah.
You know,
you,
you hear that,
that's crazy.
But you can control your mind if you're,
if you are what your mind believes it is,
then he,
if he thinks he's a,
he's cleaning out his body,
his brain will think he's cleaning out his body and it might actually have
something to it,
you know,
like
actually happening.
I mean,
either way more it's actually happening,
right?
I mean,
I was there and I have to report it.
Honestly,
I feel like that's my,
that's my mission to come back and I feel like it's one of the reasons why it
happened to me so I could talk about it and,
you know,
talking to you guys and get,
get it out there.
But the next thing I did was,
um,
was I looked at my business and very lucidly looked at all of my marketing
channels and different things.
Um,
thought about Alpha brain,
thought about the different things,
thought about,
you know,
very,
very conservative Republican type thinking about my life and my business.
And I'd saw some channels that I was working hard to produce and I was like,
there's no resources there.
And I could v physically visualize,
you know,
where there was pools in these tubes that were feeding like a giant machine.
I was like,
well I'm trying to build this tube to this pool of resources,
but there's nothing there.
Like I got to cut that one off.
I was like,
this one is good but it's blocked.
You know,
they've got to change that,
change the marketing,
you know,
change something on that.
So or you know,
think about this formula or that and I could visualize it perfectly and you
know,
right now business is going great.
So,
so you saw it it and metaphors.
You saw it in a different sense than you saw it as you know,
here's,
here's a product,
here's the marketing.
Instead of that you saw it as almost like energy or
thank feet.
It was like feeding,
it was like feeding a machine like gas,
fuel.
Now Dj,
do you have any idea?
Did you talk to it like the other people?
Were they also doing the same things are where other people are like did I saw
the dancing
phone is so much louder than everybody else's.
You suck on that thing,
dude,
you get up in here like this,
back off a little bit.
Everybody,
everybody else
so whereas other people like like just like seeing dancing bears.
Yeah.
They're like,
yeah,
they were seeing their own demons or spirits or are different things.
Did you guys have shared visions?
No.
No shared vision.
No shared visits.
That's one of the things that when they first discovered it,
the the,
when they started bringing it back to the Western world,
they tried to call it telepathy mean.
Yeah,
because?
Because of shared experiences,
but because of the rules of a scientific rules of nomenclature because the
isolated,
the compound is harming already.
One of the compounds they went with that because it was the first description of
it,
but they were going to call it telepathy dean because of the shared experiences,
but you didn't have any of that.
There was some like husband and wife couples in different huts that did that
we're witnessing.
One would just witnessed the others entire experience.
It'd be like they would try and talk to each other about it and in fact,
yeah,
I know I saw the whole thing.
So that happened.
But as far as like the group in my setting,
it seemed to be more closely linked to um,
family,
you know,
family ties or relationship,
romantic ties,
things like that.
Not necessarily what,
so the shared experiences are with people that already have a relationship.
That's what seemed to be happening in this.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
You were already tuned in together.
You're already well,
you know,
there's that feeling always when you're in a relationship that you become a part
of that person.
You know?
I mean,
I think every deep intense relationships that I've ever had,
you feel like it's more than just two people hanging out together.
Somehow or another,
you connect on some,
I don't want to say spiritual energy,
so some sort of intangible level,
which is why breaking up is so painful because a part of you is literally
missing.
You cannot feel whole.
You can't sleep,
you can't eat,
you don't feel right because some of you is missing.
So that would kind of make sense that those are the type of people that would
have a shared experience because they literally have,
their souls
are somehow or another connected.
They have some sort of a inexorable bond.
And that's,
and that's what,
that's what played itself out.
So you didn't have any experiences with your mom.
Your mom only did it once.
Now she did it three times.
She did it three times,
three times.
She do it with you,
with the Dragon.
And she was actually in that room that time and she said she was,
she didn't see what I saw.
I mean,
it wasn't because it.